euh qu'avons-nous fait après euh comm
qu'avons-nous fait pour renforcer euh
renforcer cela il y a eu euh d'abord je
dirais des des des sujets que je
qualifierais presque de euh de culturel
c'est-à-dire que euh ça a représenta une
euh un tel choc pour tout le monde pour
toute la France et pour l'éducation
nationale en particulier que euh il y a
eu un cran supplémentaire je dirais dans
la culture du signalement chacun a
compris que euh c'était important de
d'aller euh d'aller plus loin en la
matière
il y a eu aussi à ce
moment-là le sentiment qu'il était
absolument nécessaire d'aller beaucoup
plus loin dans la formation complète et
totale de l'ensemble des personnels de
l'Éducation nationale ce qui tout de
suite nous renvoie aux enjeux d'échelle
de l'éducation nationale c'est-à-dire
que faut toujours le rappeler même si
vous le savez bien que on parle de plus
d'un million de de fonctionnaires de
plus de 12 millions d'élèves euh et que
évidemment il y a pas toujours une
homogénéité de de toutes les compétences
de tous les réflexes de de l'ensemble
des enjeux de culture professionnelle
dans tous les domaines et que cette
c'est évidemment ce gigantisme suppose
ensuite des formes de d'effet matriciel
disons que l'on doit rechercher dans
dans dans l'action qui est dans l'action
qui est menée concrètement ce qui a été
fait sous la responsabilité de
l'inspecteur général horaire honoraire
auin ça a été la création d'un système
de de formation qu'on appelé le système
des miles
puisque de manière très approfondie nous
avons formé 1000 personnes qui à leur
tour sont devenus les formateurs de
formateurs à l'échelle du pays selon un
un système qui s'est déployé qui dont je
peux pas rendre compte aujourd'hui
nétant plus en fonction mais c'est déjà
des centaines de milliers de gens qui
sont qui ont été concernés par par cette
formation que ce soit les cadres ou
l'ensemble des des professeurs et et
personnel administratif de de la maison
éducation nationale